it was a very interesting thing for me
in the moment that I start research this
period of time I got a lot of shocking
information that I never knew about it
about this time that it was before the
West exists before the oil rush before
the gold rush and just to Maine has just
cross the country which was Lewis and
Clark and and in this time in the middle
of America use born a party has just
sold to United States Louisiana there
was a lot of French people French
Canadians you know British people
British Canadians and obviously a lot of
Mexicans that has just been independence
by Spain Spanish hundreds of Native
American tribes and a lot of obviously
people from the East Coast American
people from every part of Europe coming
into the country and and I think that it
was a melting pot with no law that
everybody was trying to find their way
surviving in very tough conditions in a
known territory and and I think that
something very striking is like the same
story of Colin Ellison in my country
only when the Spanish arrived was kind
of the same story
that that they encountered the clash of
cultures and and these forts were built
to get profit from everything they can
find from nature and obviously in that
time woman in in France and in London
especially they were wearing these
beaver hats and they were very expensive
and funny enough I found a shocking
thing that they must the the biggest
income in the United States was beaver
pelts and the animal pelts were the most
important profit kind of thing so they
came to look for those animals they
almost extent it and obviously by
cutting every tree killing every animal
they create a lot of pain and impact all
what the resources of these communities
were in that time so there was a
blindness of all these and all these
people were trying to survive in the
nature that was trapped Rettendon by
animal attacks by other cultures attacks
by diseases they were kind
relating each other most of the trappers
were getting you know relations with
native woman and some of them has
families some of them reject them some
of them hiding them and most of these
guys were very coming from very poor
families very illiterate and these four
were exploiting them with very tough
conditions so the conditions for a
worker in that time was really tough so
all those things in a way I found it
fascinated to create a film base
obviously in the spine of the film based
on this factual this historical fact
that happened to Hugh glass which was
attacked by a bear and that was kind of
this mind but obviously the context was
very rich you know
Alejandro and I both went into it
looking to do more than just a revenge
type story we really um we kind of felt
that that was in a lot of ways it was
empty kind of a goal without reward so
we what we found we wanted to grasp onto
was kind of the humanity of it and
Glass's journey and what would kind of
drive someone you know the human spirit
to overcome the things that he that we
were going to put him through
and so building the father-son element
was like huge it was it was the you know
one of the very first things that came
with the story that we knew we needed
more and then so it was great when I had
that element in there but then Alejandro
comes on and he he also adds with the
Arikara chief and the daughter so that
you have kind of this parallel journey
almost and it becomes it is its father
and their children it's it's glass
trying to get a piece of his son back
while at the same time the auricular
chief is trying to get his daughter and
what I thought was so beautiful about
how he did it was that it it opened
things up that so that you see that
these two very different men from very
different cultures who on a battlefield
might be fighting to the death
they're now kind of sharing the same the
same parallel journey and it just yeah I
just love that we can't talk about the
Butte in this film without recognizing
the work of Emanuel chief of Lubezki
who you have collaborated with
is unbelievable photographer Hugh glass
being the sort of isolationist that he
is I think much of the film for me was a
relationship with with Cibo I think that
you know from the onset he has you know
he's always the outsider he has a Native
American son but he is trying to
disappear in the context of this
environment in order to survive and
those are some of the things he's trying
to instill in his son so he's always
within and without he's there he's an
operative is a scout but he's trying to
remain detached from this whole wave of
of capitalism surging towards the
wilderness so he's a survivor much like
every character in this movie is a
survivor from Tom Hardy to you know the
Arikara chief to to you know to the bear
but so much of my journey was Hugh glass
being this incredibly isolated character
and that relationship that I you know I
had with Chivo
was a very intimate one because because
for me as an actor this was
predominantly pushing a narrative in
almost complete silence which was part
of the excitement about this journey for
me as how to convey a narrative without
words and so much of that was through
the work with qi boat a lot of the time
during the the rehearsal process because
i don't know if many people here know
how this film was done but it was very
unique for all the actors we would work
with all the different departments
during the day and it would almost be
like you know doing doing theater during
the dinner was like live television for
the last hour and a half of magic light
so we had to make sure that certain
nuances were captured certain beats were
captured certain emotional moments were
captured and we got to rehearse that
during the day and it gave you a great
comfort I feel I felt I started to feel
towards you know certainly towards you
know the beginning of the process it was
it was hard to adjust at first but it
really gave you a great comfort because
you knew that that the cameraman was
going to be there Shiva was going to be
there at the exact right moment for
these beats and you got to think about
them in great detail and
and so a lot of the dance for me
throughout the whole course of the film
was with Chivo and capturing those
little nuances and and you know what
they were able to do certainly and some
of these vast incredibly beautiful
action sequences is capture incredible
intimacy with the characters and then
weave seamlessly around to an
unbelievable David Lean style shot you
know it I've never quite seen anything
cinematically like that and what what
they what they achieve with the actors
in this in this film and in some of
these shots I think is quite
groundbreaking in that respect I've
never seen him movie accomplished that
one of the very first images I ever
showed Alejandro wasn't a Rick or a
hunter who was very monk like his his
hat was a hood and Alejandro really
responded to that I think there was a
med of strong metaphor there for him and
the other was a Russian icon of a monk
an image and those two kind of combined
to inspire glasses look because he's out
in the wilderness not for the same
mercenary or monetary reasons as Leo was
saying as the other trappers but it was
almost his Cathedral and there was a
commune of glass with the animals they
were in a mutual survival event and I
think he is his outfit or his costume is
very kind of monk-like or st. Francis
decision in in some respect Alejandro is
one of the few directors who understands
how to shoot a film how to design a film
in a way that opens the door to sound
design actually participating in the
storytelling and certainly true in in
the whole bear sequence the fact that we
have those close close shots of Leo and
the bear in that sequence allows us to
get into both of their heads in a sense
in a way that we wouldn't
if he had done it with medium shots and
the big challenge with the bear was to
make it completely believable but cover
the range of emotional notes that the
bear had to have at one point the bear
is shot and and is obviously in in
distress and I figured the best way to
get that idea across was with its
breathing and to make it clear that was
having a difficult time breathing and
unfortunately I didn't have any
recordings of wounded heard distressed
bears and so the this labored breathing
that you hear especially when the mother
bear goes off screamed to the right is
actually a hoarse breathing that was
having a difficult time breathing that I
did have a recording of and so then the
trick is making the transition so that
you believe that it's one creature all
the way through allowed to really set
the table in the context for the bear
attack especially by you know wanting
everything to be based in reality and
you know we looked at a lot of reference
footage and we did a lot of research
basically the bear team went to bear
school to really figure out all the
nuances of how the Bears were behaving
in a very naturalistic way to really
sell this scene you know we we went for
all of the nuances of motion and and
even the beats in between which I think
ultimately we're probably the scariest
moments you know these anticipation
moments of not just the mauling itself
but you know what's going to happen next
you know so Alejandra really the context
which we set this up and the
collaboration with Chivo working with a
camera and Leos performance and his
willingness to really be physical to
really help us sell the work was really
key I mean everybody coming together
visual effects just sort of bring it all
together in the end but you know setting
the table properly really really helped
us this is the movie that unfolds in the
early 19th century it's a period film
and yet I suspect you feel it has a lot
to say about man versus nature today
about First Nations and Native American
people
it's crazy that you're asking me that
because I was sitting here saying god I
want to talk more here we are your mic
no no the end in reference to what you
were saying what I was left with from
this movie you know historically we look
back at human nature and what we've done
to you know other other races what we've
done to the natural world we say God how
ignorant we must have been how how
short-sighted and and here we have this
first wave this first influx of
capitalism out east and of course it was
a genocide of the of the Native American
population we took from the natural
world as Alejandro said we you know we
carved up nature for for our for our for
our own comfort but here here we're
looking at them you know the modern era
and we think we've learned these lessons
from the past and having done I was
doing a climate change documentary
simultaneously to doing this this film
and I got to go to you know places where
the Canadian tar sands were you know a
swaths of forests the size of Florida
were being cut down for what is one of
the most destructive practices on planet
earth and of course we got to go visit
first nations relocation neighborhoods
where these people were basically you
know their entire lands were poisoned
their culture was sort of wiped out
because they couldn't hunt they couldn't
eat the fish that were causing cancer to
their people and they had to you know
that they're continually having to you
know buy food from a government that is
massively overpriced
we're systematically doing this in on a
mechanized scale that is uncharted
unknown that has never been done in
history so these are obvious themes to
me when you see what's this is the first
wave of that in our in an American
context and of course is Alejandro was
saying you know doing a film about
climate change
studying climactic conditions around the
world having to relocate to the southern
tip of Argentina just to find snow was
the greatest irony here we are
a bunch of I know artists saying let's
go into nature and see what it tells us
all nature was [ __ ] telling us that
the world is changing unlike ever before
2015 was the hottest year in recorded
history and these are unprecedented
weather conditions happening all over
the world and it hit us right smack in
the face and we had to shut down
production multiple times extreme
weather patterns in both directions the
locals telling us that they'd never seen
this in the history of their province so
that's what ultimately this whole era
I'm going to be left with the year of
2015 where all the tipping points
happened and we immerse ourselves in the
natural world to hear hear it for
ourselves